Structs and enumeration are value types.
And classes are reference types.
This is in fact the principal difference
between these complex objects.
Okay, so what are value types and
reference types?
When a value type is assigned to
a variable or a constant, it's copied.
An entirely new instance is created.
When a reference type is
assigned to a variable or
a constant, there is no copy.
A new reference to the original
instance is created.
This is definitely challenging
to wrap one's brain around.
But a couple examples
should clear things up.
Let's go back to our
picture frame struct.
We'll declare an instance of the picture
frame struct and call it frame.
Creative, I know.
Here I'm initializing a frame
as a 3 by 5 picture frame with
a half inch thickness.
Now we'll assign another variable,
frameForMom.
My mom always needs more picture frames.
We'll assign frameForMom
to be equal to frame.
But mom needs a 5 by 7 frame.
So we'll need to reset
the dimensions of frameForMom.
Now my question for you is what
is the width and height of frame?
I'll give you a few
seconds to think about it.
We can see in the sidebar that the
dimensions of frame are still 3 by 5.
When the frame was
assigned to frameForMom,
an entirely new copy was made.
The values 5 and 7 are held by
the copy represented by frameForMom.
The values 3 and 5 are held by
the copy represented by frame.
What if picture frame were a class?
Here's a nearly identical class,
I'm calling it classy picture frame.
Down here I'm instantiating a classy
picture frame called classy frame.
And setting its width and
height to 3 by 5.
And like I did before,
I'm creating another variable
called classyFrameForMom.
And assigning it to be
equal to classy frame.
But of course, mom needs 5 by 7 frames.
And again we ask ourselves, what will
be the width and height of ClassyFrame.
And over here in the sidebar,
we see 5 by 7.
But we never change
the dimensions of ClassyFrame.
How did that happen?
Classes are reference types.
So when ClassyFrame was assigned to
ClassyFrameForMom, no copy was made.
Instead, a new reference was made.
This means that classyFrame and
classyFrameForMom both
refer to the same instance.
Here we're changing the value of
the underlying instance to 5 by 7, and
both references are affected.